[Music]
former president Trump still faces other
criminal investigations in addition to
this hush money case we've been talking
about all morning including a special
counsel's inquiry into the January 6
assault on the Capitol and his handling
of documents that were marked classified
that were founded as Florida home the
district attorney in Atlanta as you've
heard is also weighing charges in
Trump's effort to interfere in the 2020
vote count in Georgia let's focus now on
what will happen here in New York City
next week Tuesday they say is a day
attorney Joe Joe tacopenis defending the
former president in the Manhattan DA's
case it's good to see you again Mr
takapina let's start right away with
this question when did you and the
president find out about this indictment
we were all led to believe that it was
going to be delayed sometime
yeah we were led to believe the same
thing Gail I mean it was uh it was
yesterday at around 5 30 in the
afternoon you know much later in the day
than normal but that's when we learned
have you had a chance to look at look at
the indictment I know it's sealed have
you had a chance to see it
we've not we've not you know people are
reporting how many counts are and
whatnot it's all you know news to us I
mean we've unfortunately gotten a lot of
our information in this Saga uh through
media reports we've not seen it when
it's unsealed
um we will take a look at it
well if you haven't seen it how can how
can you and your team say that it's a
political Witch Hunt that is politically
motivated if we don't really know
exactly what's in it yet
no I know what's in it what I don't know
is the number of counts and what the
Council premised on but I do know the
subject matter of the indictment they've
made that clear to us it's about a civil
confidentiality agreement executed by uh
president Trump's ex-lawyer a lawyer for
Stormy Daniels and and nothing more
um so we know it's premised and based on
on that fact pattern which doesn't
equate to a crime not even close to a
crime if you want to look at campaign
Finance laws and discuss that FEC
chairman have come on and said there is
no crime here they FEC looked at this
and found no wrongdoing whatsoever so
it's we know what the subject matter is
we know what the basis of the charges
um we don't know the exact counts or how
they're formally in the counts but that
doesn't really matter
well based on your statement that you
made just now how worried is Donald
Trump about this indictment
oh he's not worried at all I mean he's
upset angry
um he is being persecuted politically
that is clear to many people not only on
the right but on the left and we as
Americans honestly should be concerned
today it's Donald Trump tomorrow it's
going to be a Democrat the day after
that it could be your your brother your
son your daughter and and we have to be
concerned about the rule of law falling
because what's happened here is this is
a case that would not have been brought
against another individual in this
country if his name wasn't Donald Trump
pursuing pursued by a a prosecutor who
has uh obviously very diverse political
views from the president so it's a a
very troubling case because there's no
crime here the United States attorney's
office who has jurisdiction over federal
election campaigns turned this down the
FEC the federal election committee
turned this down and said there was no
wrongdoing so
um how a state prosecutor is going to
prosecute a federal election campaign
violation which they think is a
violation which clearly isn't if you
understand the law
um
I hear you but we just had Senator
Warren here many Democrats are saying
the same thing nobody is above the law
let's let the process play out why don't
we all just take that process why don't
we all do it
yeah go ahead yeah I agree with you
could not agree with you more
but no one's below the law either right
and we shouldn't pick the person and
then try to find the crime and if you
read that Prosecutor's book Mark
palmridge who left the office in a huff
and wrote a book
um what he said was they had Donald
Trump they despised and loathed him and
he was looking for a crime to fit the
person that's Nazi Germany era that's
communist China Soviet Union we do not
do that in this country we don't go
after people we don't like are we trying
to find a crime and that's what happened
here
all right can you just tell us briefly
the process on Tuesday what will happen
will Donald Trump show up in New York
will he be walked in the front of the
right in the front doors of the court
case in 20 seconds
yeah we're trying to work out those
Logistics um it looks like possibly
Tuesday but I don't know yet in as far
as how that all happens this is a case
of first pressure for all of us you have
Secret Service involved NYPD Court
officers Union so I'm not sure exactly
how it plays out but we'll get through
it we will get through it and we will be
there thank you very much for your time
this morning